celebración en Marruecos Los Leones del
Atlas se impusieron A Canadá por dos a
uno para clasificar octavos de final y
además como primeros de grupo Los
africanos saltaron al campo con mucha
convicción sabiendo que podían ganar a
Canadá ya le habían ganado a Bélgica fue
así como se adelantaron con un tanto de
silles después de un grave fallo del
portero canadiense posteriormente en
Círculo culminó a la perfección un pase
de hakimi para poner el 2-0 y tanto de
la tranquilidad que se convierte en el
primer jugador de Marruecos que marca en
dos mundiales marcó en Rusia 2018 y
marca también aquí en Qatar Al filo del
Descanso llegó un tanto para Canadá gol
en propia puerta de ayer que hizo que
saltaran los nervios para los marroquíes
que en la segunda parte entregaron la
pelota para los canadienses pero
sufrieron sufrir Para volver a unos
octavos de final Como lo hicieron ya en
1986 cuando los eliminó Alemania con un
golazo de los dharmateos al final del
partido Marruecos es la primera
selección árabe que avanza a los octavos
de final aquí en este mundial de Qatar
primer mundial en país árabe y lo hace
aquí en el estadio de altumama un
estadio que como Ven a mis espaldas
tiene una forma de gafilla una forma una
prenda de vestir una especie de gorro
muy típico del mundo árabe mucha
celebración mucho simbolismo para los
marroquíes que son una importante
hinchada aquí en doha